from the daily mail
says training goes woke boot camp for
the navy to include classes on suicide
prevention hazing racism and sexual
assault after numerous crisis over the
past number of years
so u.s navy said it would expand its
eight-week boot camp program to include
two more weeks of classes focusing on
suicide prevention sexual assault hazing
and racism
the change the first major overhaul in
nearly 20 years comes as the navy
grapples with major
issues aboard the ships over the years
that include failures to address sexual
assaults fires and deadly collisions and
the rise of extremism within the ranks
um
uh rear admiral jennifer couture who
heads the naval service training command
told the associated press that the two
extra weeks of classes would reinforce
the behavior desired in a u.s naval
officer
she said quote we're telling our
recruits here are all the things that we
expect you to do and here's how we
expect you to behave and act she said
adding that it involves treating people
with respect and holding peers
accountable
so this is navy boot camp now
teaching about racism
treating people with respect
the kind of thing that you would get
from a from a guidance counselor
you know
and now this is this is what we're doing
in the military
you know i guess i'm old school and
old-fashioned and uh i still believe
at least for me
um as a citizen of the united states
relying on the military to protect us
the only thing i care about for people
in the military
is that they're very good at killing the
bad guys
that is really it
at least if i were to make a list
of the qualities that i would think are
the most important
that's number one two three four and
five
and then maybe we could list a couple
things underneath that but that's that's
that's the top five right there
good at killing the bad guys
and then when you find out about
the chaos aboard these ships
collisions fires and they're telling us
themselves this is this is happening
more often now than it used to
might that be because
we are not emphasizing
skill
as much as we used to
[Music]
of course that's it
but their way of solving that problem is
to do more of the thing that caused the
problem in the first place
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated